joining me down the line is Leia Harper
and she's a podcaster but also the
author of undressing Bitcoin not Bitcoin
Bitcoin Leia thank you and welcome uh
for joining me this evening and just
explain
Central Bank digital currencies this
isn't just the bank of England
considering this is it
exactly currently more than 90 of
central banks globally are all working
on bringing out East Central Bank
digital currency and I think it's really
important to elaborate on what exactly
that is a central bank digital currency
is basically what we have now so it's
fiat currency but it's going to be
entirely digital which means absolutely
in the control of the government and the
central bank so as you mentioned
government since they own it they're
able to program it in a way that we've
never seen before so as you said if for
whatever reason you don't do as you're
told and you don't pick three vaccines
four vaccines or whatever it is the
money can just be programmed to be used
against you the perfect example is right
now during this supposed climate crisis
where they want to implement a carbon
allowance so how do you do that well
it's very simple you just program the
money in a way that you cannot do with
the current cash that we have you
program the money so if for example you
have a barbecue and you um want to buy
some steaks and burgers some sausages
whatever it is
um you could actually reach your carbon
allowance and when you go to fill up
your car it could get declined because
you reach your carbon allowance so it's
a really efficient way for governments
to implement their political and woke
agendas through the money
all of this of course Leia all of this
will be denied at every stage by
government but when you look at the
incredible overreach of government over
the course of the last few years nothing
is impossible now I know that you are a
great advocate for Bitcoin perhaps for
other cryptocurrencies too and and it's
this this program is not here to give
investment advice but I'm thinking to
myself
if we move towards full Central Bank
digital currencies and I don't want
government to control potentially every
aspect of my life presumably this could
be the biggest thing that's ever
happened to bitcoin and other crypto
coins
which means outside of um any CEO or
centralized control nobody can freeze it
nobody can touch your funds as long as
it's in a non-custodial wallet and
that's the most important thing and you
know you don't have to buy Bitcoin for
an investment purposes it's about being
a sovereign individual because money is
the is the energy which fuels your life
so if you don't have control of your
money you don't have control over
anything in you in my opinion really
just become a slave because if the
government can make your money expire if
the government can freeze it um in the
name of terrorism or national security
then what Freedom do you have in society
as an individual you have none and
that's why of course I'm a huge advocate
for Bitcoin because nobody can touch it
there's no CEO there's no centralized
Authority fully decentralized in the
control of just you but but number one
you know we've got to be honest it is
extremely volatile in terms of price and
number two we have seen a very large
number of bankruptcies in what in what
is a pretty unregulated market so there
are risks here aren't there
so I'll start with the price firstly it
is volatile everything is volatile but
if you zoom out and look at Bitcoin over
the last um decade you can see that it
is moving on an upward trajectory again
this isn't investment advice but long
term if you do zoom out it does seem to
be some form of store of value and
secondly with regards to bankruptcies
those are centralized exchanges and I
would never Advocate leaving your money
on a centralized exchange that's really
the same as leaving it in a bank with no
assurance and no regulation so don't do
that
nope okay what Leia thank you once again
for joining me on this program thank you
very much indeed